SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BACKER FOR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTEZ THE ALLEN DODD
YOU'RE AWESOME EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG WESO
HURTADO JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED
LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN
NEWMAN. NIELSEN A CHOI BOGUE PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO INNER TURN
ON BURKE WHY CASTING WIENER WILK. GOOD MORNING LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
BUT THE MEMBERS AND OUR GAS TO
BE ON THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED
IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY CENTER
LEYVA AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
CENTER RIGHT CASKEY SENATOR
LEYVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS LET US PRAY NOW MORE
THAN EVER LET US BE THE ONES WHO
WILL NOT TURN AWAY. LET US BE
THE ONES WHO WILL GO FARTHER
INTO THE RACK AND DEEPER INTO
THE RUBBLE LET US BE THE ONES
WHO WILL ENTER INTO THE PLACES
OF DEVASTATION BEYOND BELIEF AND
DESPAIR BEYOND OUR IMAGINING AND
LET ADULT THERE LET US LISTEN
FOR THE SPIRIT THAT BROODED OVER
THE FORMOSA BISS AND THERE LET
US LOOK AGAIN FOR THE GOD WHO
GATHERED UP THE CHAOS AND BEGAN
TO CREATE LET US BE THE ONES.
WHO WILL GIVE OURSELVES TO THE
WORK OF MAKING AGAIN AND TO THE
IN LAWS BEGINNING OF CREATION. A
MAN. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. THE INDIVIDUAL. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN FIRST
ORDER OF BUSINESS TODAY IS TO
WELCOME BACK SENATOR WILK WHO IS
REJOINING THE SENATE SESSION
THIS MORNING'S WELCOME BACK
CENTER WILK. THE WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
. SEEING NO ONE WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WHICH
WILL BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLYWILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
MOVE TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
COUPLE MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED UNDER MOTIONS.
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES SENATOR
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE FILE NUMBER ONE OF THREE
SB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX FROM THE
KITCHEN COUNTER AT THE REQUEST.
OF THE AUTHOR FOR PURPOSES AND-
THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE SENATOR
WILK. YOUR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM ONE OH FOUR S. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THANK YOU SIR WILK ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
OUR MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
SAYING NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE MEMBERS WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF ITEMS ON THE DAILY
FILE THAT WERE TO TAKE UP THIS
MORNING FIRST WE'RE GONNA GO TO
SECOND READING SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY
TWO. THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO THIRD SENATE THIRD
READING. THE FIRST ITEM OF THE
DAY IS ITEMS. FILE IN FIFTY
THREE. WHICH IS SENATE BILL
EIGHT SIXTY SIX. BY SENATOR
WIENER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY SIX BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO MINORS CENTER WINNER IS READY
CENTER WE KNOW YOUR RECOGNIZED I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES- SB EIGHT SIXTY SIX-
WILL ALLOW- TEENAGERS IT'S ALL
THE SEVENTEEN TO PROTECT THEIR
OWN HEALTH- BY GETTING.
VACCINATED AND OF COURSE LIMITED
THE VACCINES THAT ARE APPROVED
BY THE FDA. AND THAT MEET THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES. SB EIGHT
SIXTY SIX- IS BUILT ON A LONG
STANDING EXISTING CALIFORNIA
LAW. THAT ALLOWS TEENAGERS TO
MAKE CERTAIN MEDICAL DECISIONS
FOR THEMSELVES- UNDER EXISTING
LONG STANDING CALIFORNIA LAW-
TEENAGERS CAN RECEIVE THE HPV
VACCINE AND A HEPATITIS B.
VACCINE ON THEIR OWN. IN
ADDITION TO ANY OTHER- SEXUAL
HEALTH TREATMENT. TEENAGERS ON
THEIR OWN- CAN SEEK AND OBTAIN A
TREATMENT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT- FOR DRUG AND
ALCOHOL RELATED DISORDERS. AND
FOR OTHER CONDITIONS RIGHT NOW
WE TRUSTED EDITORS TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS. FOR THEMSELVES OF
MINORS OF ANY AGE CAN CONSENT TO
BIRTHCONTROL. AND ABORTION. YES
A TEENAGER CANNOT GO IN AND GET
A FLU SHOT. UNLESS THEIR PARENTS
ARE CONSENT. EVEN IF A TEENAGER
DESPERATELY WANTS A VACCINE
WANTS TO PROTECT THEIR OWN
HEALTH RIGHT NOW THEY CANNOT DO
SO ON THEIR OWN AND WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MANY TEENAGERS THAT
WANT TO PROTECT THEIR OWN HEALTH
AND THEY'RE UNABLE TO DO SO
WHETHER BECAUSE A PARENT DOESN'T
BELIEVE IN VACCINES AND IS
PROHIBITING THEM. FROM
PROTECTING THEIR OWN HEALTH. OR
WHETHER BECAUSE OF MEDICAL
NEGLECT. AND WE KNOW THAT
THEY'RE ALL TOO MANY CHILDREN IN
THE STATE WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM
MEDICAL NEGLECT. OR BECAUSE A
PARENT IS SIMPLY TOO BUSY TO GET
AROUND TO IT OR GETS DELAYED.
AND THEN IT'S THAT TEENAGERS
HEALTH THAT IS ON THE LINE AS A
RESULT- THERE ARE OTHER STATES
WE WILL NOT BE THE FIRST THERE
ARE OTHER STATES THAT ALLOW
TEENAGERS- TO GROWING IT BACK
SENATE ON THEIR OWN INCLUDING
RHODE ISLAND SOUTH CAROLINA
OREGON ALABAMA AND WASHINGTON.
DC R. THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
COBRA I KNOW THAT IS WHAT'S YOU
KNOW MINE FOR ALL OF US
OBVIOUSLY. BUT THIS IS ABOUT ANY
VACCINE THAT IS RECOMMENDED. FOR
THIS AGE GROUP WE KNOW THAT
MEASLES TRAGICALLY WE THOUGHT WE
HAD ELIMINATED AND THE U. S.
IT'S BACK- WE KNOW- THAT MONTHS
IS STILL AROUND. WE KNOW THAT
EVEN POLIO WHICH WE HAVE
ELIMINATED IN THIS COUNTRY IS
STILL CIRCULATING IN VARIOUS
PARTS OF THE WORLD AND COULD
COME BACK TO THE U. S. IF. THE
MISINFORMATION AND HESITANCY
CONTINUES. AND THIS IS ABOUT
ALLOWING. THESE YOUNG PEOPLE. TO
TAKE STEPS TO PROTECT THEIR OWN
HEALTH. AND WE SHOULD ALLOW THEM
TO DO THAT. NEARLY ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIA TEENAGERS ARE NOT
VACCINATED AGAINST CODE NINETEEN
. AND WE COULD TALK ABOUT OTHER
VACCINES AS WELL LARGE NUMBERS
OF TEENS WHO ARE NOT VACCINATED
MANY OF WHOM WOULD LIKE TO GET
VACCINATED AND WOULD DO SO IF WE
RECOGNIZED THEIR AGENCY AND
THEIR AUTONOMY TO DO SO. WHICH
IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
WINNER SENATOR NIELSEN. MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE THIS IS BUT A NOTHER
OF THE CONTINUE. OF LEGISLATION
TO UNDERMINE PARENTAL AUTHORITY
AND PARENTAL RESPONSIBILITY.
PARACHA SHOULD ALWAYS BE
INVOLVED IN DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR CHILDREN PARTICULARLY THE
YOUNGEST AND THIS IS OF THAT
CLASS. I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
AGENCIES ENTITIES. THE SIDE THEY
KNOW BETTER THAN THE BLOOD BOND
OF PARENTHOOD. IT'S A CONCERN TO
ME GREATLY FOR AMERICAN SOCIETY
. THAT WE CONTINUE TO UNDERMINE
THE AUTHORITY AND THE ABILITY OF
PARENTS. TO CONTROL AND INPUT
DECISIONS OTHER MORE MINOR
CHILDREN. SEVENTEEN YUP THAT'S
GETTING ON ITS WAY TO MATURITY
BUT YOU'RE NOT THERE YET. AND IT
DOES NOT SERVE US TO CONTINUE TO
TAKE AWAY THAT RESPONSIBILITY
AND THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
BLOOD BOND PARENTS OF OUR YOUTH
IRISH A NOBLE. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY AS A
CO AUTHOR OF S. B. EIGHT SIXTY
SIX AS WE CONTINUE TO DEAL WITH
THE INCREASING POLITICIZATION OF
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC THIS
BILL IS A SOUND AND SADLY
NECESSARY PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURE
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO HAS ALREADY NOTED
QUITE CLEARLY THE MEASURE BEFORE
US. APPLIES TO VACCINATIONS
SHERLEY AND WILL NOT FORCE TEENS
TO GET VACCINATED RATHER IT
EMPOWERS YOUNG PEOPLE OVER
TWELVE YEARS OLD TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THE EMINENTLY FULL
OPTION OF PROTECTING THEIR OWN
HEALTH IS PART OF BEING
RESPONSIBLE MEMBERS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE AMPLE PROOF
THAT MANY YOUNG PEOPLE ARE SMART
ENOUGH AND FULLY CAPABLE OF
MAKING INFORMED AND INTELLIGENT
DECISIONS. AND WHILE WE SHOULD
ALWAYS GRANT DEFERENCE TO
FAMILIES IN THE COMPLICATED AND
PERSONAL BUSINESS OF RAISING
CHILDREN WE SHOULD NOT IN THE
MIDST OF THIS CHALLENGING A
PRECARIOUS TIME ALLOW THE
POLITICAL OR RELIGIOUS VIEWS OF
SOMEONE'S PARENTS TO STAND IN
THE WAY OF THAT PERSON
PROTECTING HIS OR HER OWN HEALTH
AND THE HEALTH OF OTHERS. IN
THIS MOMENT INDEED ON THIS DAY
ON WHICH AMERICANS BEAR WITNESS
TO THE INCREDIBLY SAD AND UNDER
THE MILESTONE OF OVER ONE
MILLION DEATHS IN THE UNITED
STATES BECAUSE BY COVERT THIS
MEASURE COULD NOT BE MORE TIMELY
MORE MORE VALID AND NOT
WITHSTANDING ALL OF THE POLITICS
AND POLARIZATION OF THE PANDEMIC
IT IS A FACT. THAT THE VACCINES
DEVELOPED AGAINST THE STARS KOBE
TO VIRUS AND ITS VARIANTS SUB
BEEN SCIENTIFICALLY AND
THOROUGHLY PROVEN TO PROTECT
PEOPLE FROM SEVERE OUTCOMES
ESPECIALLY FROM DYING MOREOVER
AND JUST AS IMPORTANTLY AT POINT
THERE'S COMPREHENSIVE EVIDENCE
THE COVERT VACCINES ARE SAFE. AS
SAFE AS ANY OF THE OTHER LIFE
SAVING IMMUNIZATIONS TO WHICH WE
- I. HAVE ADDED FOR THIS. OF
PUBLIC. AND THE STEADY EXCHANGE
OF LIFESPANS IN OUR MODERN
SOCIETY THE MORE CALIFORNIANS
WHO HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
LIFESAVING VACCINES THE SOONER
WE CAN PUT THE PANDEMIC. FULLY
BEHIND US EMPOWERING YOUNG
PEOPLE WITH ACCESS TO CODE
VACCINES IS ESSENTIAL TO KEEPING
STUDENTS IN SCHOOL NOT ONLY FOR
THEIR EDUCATION BUT ALSO THEIR
PHYSICAL. AND MENTAL WELL BEING
AS WELL I COMMEND MY COLLEAGUES
FOR BRINGING FOR THIS MEASURE I
STAND PROUDLY WITH HIM. AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN CENTER PAN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS- I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SP EIGHT SIX
SIX AS A PEDIATRICIAN AND A
FATHER OF. WO CHILDREN ONE OF
WHOM IS A TEENAGER AND ANOTHER
ONE WHO WILL TURN TWELVE
ACTUALLY- LATER THIS YEAR. THIS
BILL IS IMPORTANT TO ALLOW.
YOUNG PEOPLE TO SELF CONSENT TO
FTA. RECOMMENDED AND H. C. I. T.
RECOMMENDED VACCINES AND AS A
PEDIATRICIAN I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE CAPABLE MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR OWN HEALTH
CARE. AND IT IS UP TO THIS
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW THEM TO DO
SO NOW- CERTAINLY HEARD
TESTIMONY ABOUT- PARENTS IN FACT
THIS IS A PHYSICIAN AND SOMEONE
WHO PARTICULARLY FOCUSES ON
TAKING CARE OF CHILDREN AND- ARE
USED. OF COURSE WE ENGAGE
PARENTS. BOYS FRIDAY'S
APPEARANCE. BUT WE ALSO KNOWN
FORTY THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH- AND IT IS TRULY
UNFORTUNATE AS A PHYSICIAN WHO'S
HAD TO DEAL WITH CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT AND SO FORTH THAT
SOMETIMES- PARENTS ALWAYS ACT IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
CHILDREN. BUT ACTUALLY EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY OFTENTIMES PARENTS
ARE TRYING THEIR BEST. BUT THEY
MAY BE FOR A CERTAIN THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES THE MEDIA WAY
RIGHT THERE MAY BE DIFFERENT
FAMILY ARRANGEMENTS AND SO
FORTH. THOSE BECOME BARRIERS TO
THE USE GETTING CARE. SO WE
TRIED IT WE CERTAINLY TRY TO
ENGAGE THE PARENTS AND THE
PARENTS READING GAUGE WITH US
BUT SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU HAVE A
MIGRANT FAMILY AND THE PARENTS
HAPPEN TO BE WORKING AND IT'S
NOT A COUNTY YOUR FATHER WHERE
THEY CAN'T GET THERE. AND
MEANWHILE THEIR GRANDPARENTS OR
MAYBE AN OLDER SIBLING OR AN
UNCLE OR ONCE PRIMARILY TAKING
CARE OF THEM BUT YET THEY DON'T
HAVE THE LEGAL AUTHORITY BECAUSE
LISTEN NOW THEN GO TO COURT AND
THAT IS BECAUSE THE PARENTS KNOW
THE VENTS THE COMEBACK IN
SERVICE. SO THESE BECOME
BARRIERS TO CARE. AND ANSWER- I
THINK WELL SOME. DO THIS BILL AS
- THE SITUATION ONE WHICH- FOR
EXAMPLE MAYBE A YOUTH IN THE
PARENT MAY DISAGREE. ACTUALLY IS
A PEACHES ALL TELL YOU THE MORE
COMMON CIRCUMSTANCES IS THAT THE
PARENT ACTUALLY AGREES. BUT THEY
WERE YOU KNOW IT AGAIN THERE IS
A MAYBE WORKING TWO JOBS IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THEY WERE NOT
ABLE TO ACCOMPANY THE TOWN. IN
FACT A SIMPLE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
ACTUALLY TO TELL YOU WHAT YOU
WORK FOR THE PAIR AND THEY GOT
THEIR FIRST VACCINE. IS MANY
VACCINES ARE SERIES. AND THEN
BECOME FOR FOLLOW UP VISIT BUT
BECAUSE THE PARENTS ARE TOO BUSY
WITH THEIR JOBS OR OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES. THE PROPERTY
LISTING OLDER SIBLING WHO
HAPPENS TO BE YOU KNOW TWENTY
BUT- DOES HAVE FOR THEIR
GRANDPARENTS. AND THEN THE
PROBLEM IS THE SHOP IN THE
OFFICE AND I'VE SEEN THIS SO
MANY TIMES. IT WAS LIKE SORRY WE
CAN'T DO THIS. BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE PARENTS HERE TO GIVE
DIRECT PERMISSION AND WE TRY TO
REACH THE PAIR BUT THEY'RE
WORKING. THEY DON'T HAVE THE L.
L. SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY'RE AT.
WE KNOW CERTAINLY NO WORKERS
WHERE DID ALLOWED TO KEEP CELL
PHONES NEXT TO THEM ETCETERA.
AND WE CAN'T REACH A GO SORRY
AND MEANWHILE THE FAMILY
CERTAINLY TOOK- TREMENDOUS
EFFORTS TO BE SURE THEIR CHILD
BECOMING DAY CARE AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT HASN'T. I
WOULD ALSO KEEP IN MIND THAT
WHILE CERTAINLY IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ALLOWING. TEENS USE. THE SELF
CONSENT. IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
GET THE SERVICES. THERE'S
ACTUALLY A LICENSED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS TO DELIVER IT AND
HAS EXERCISED THEIR OWN
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR THAT YOU. AND I
THINK THAT'S ANOTHER LAYER OF
PROTECTION. TO ENSURE THAT- THAT
CERTAINLY IT'S NOT THAT THE USER
CAN DECIDE I WANT ANYTHING I
WANT. THERE'S ACTUALLY. A YEAH
THE A LICENSED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL SAYS THIS IS
APPROPRIATE FOR YOU. AND I WOULD
ALSO POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL IS
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON GETTING
VACCINES WHICH HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE MOST RIGOROUS TESTING AND
HAS A REQUIRES APPROVAL. AND
RECOMMENDATION FROM EXPERTS LIKE
ADVISING TO ME IN HIS ASIAN
PRACTICES. AND THAT'S WHY BY THE
WAY IN ADDITION TO BUT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES JUST VACCINATIONS THAT
ALREADY IN CALIFORNIA LAW. IN
CALIFORNIA LAW. IF A TWELVE YEAR
OLD SHOWS UP IN MY OFFICE. AND
NOT ONLY DID THEY WANT OTHER
VACCINES LIKE HPV AND HEPATITIS
B. THEY CAN CONSENT TO IT. THEY
WANNA TALK TO ME ABOUT THE NASTY
D. DRUG USE- PREGNANCY. SEXUAL
ASSAULT. I DON'T NEED TO GO ASK
THE PARENTS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THOSE USED
TO GET THE CARE AND THEY ALSO
HAVE THE PRIVACY NECESSARY TO DO
THAT. BUT I ALSO INCLUDES MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THINKING ABOUT ALL
THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WERE
STRUGGLING WITH RIGHT NOW. IN A
FORTY THE STIGMA ATTACHED TO
THAT. SO THIS BILL REALLY IS
ABOUT. REDUCING THE BARRIERS TO
GETTING LIFESAVING VACCINES AND
CERTAINLY THERE'S NO MEDICAL OR
SCIENCE BASED REASON WHY MINERS
FORMER OLDER SHOULD NOT BE ABLE
TO CONSENT TO THEM AGAIN AS A
PEDIATRICIAN WHO STUDIES CHILD
DEVELOPMENT THERE'S NO REASON TO
THINK THAT A TWELVE YEAR OLD. BY
LAW SHOULD BE ABLE TO CONSENT TO
THEM AND CERTAINLY AGAIN WITH A
LICENSED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS IS EVALUATING
THEIR STATE OF MIND AND THEIR
CONDITION. I'LL POINT OUT THAT
MANY OF THE PEOPLE OPPOSE THE
TWO TEENS CHEESE VACCINES ACT
ALSO OPPOSE ABORTION ACCESS. IN
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE MUST
HOLD THE LINE AGAINST FIGHTING
AGAINST AGENCY FOR WOMEN YOUNG
PEOPLE. FOR THAT REASON THE
ASIAN CENTER VACCINES MUST BE
TWELVE WHICH IS WHAT IT
CURRENTLY IS NOW. WE DO NOT KNOW
. THE CONSEQUENCES WERE ABORTION
ACCESS WITH AN OSCAR IF WOULD BE
IF WE START MAKING DECISIONS FOR
POLITICAL REASONS AND NOT
SCIENTIFIC ONES. SO THIS REALLY
IS ABOUT MAKING IT EASIER FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO GIVE VACCINES IT
SHOULD BE A GOOD THING. AND WE
ALSO WANT TO INCREASE HEALTHCARE
EQUITY BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S
USUALLY THE FAMILIES THAT ARE
MOST DISADVANTAGED OF THE
LARGEST BARRIERS TO GETTING
VACCINATIONS INCLUDING BY THE
WAY GETTING CAN. THIS- CONSENT
SO WHAT IS TIME OFF WORK FOR A
WELLNESS VISIT OUR FORGOTTEN
PAPERWORK. ANY CHANGE THAT MAKES
IT EASIER TO GIVE ACTUALLY IS
THE ONE WE MUST TAKE. AND WE OF
COURSE KNOW HOW FOR VACCINATIONS
ARE TOO NOR PROTECTING THE
CHILD'S HEALTH BE SURE THAT THEY
CAN GO TO. THAT THE AMOUNTS IN A
HOSPITAL. HIGH RISK FAMILY
MEMBERS RIGHT I MEAN.
TRANSACTION OFTEN UNTIL WE GETS
A PARTICULAR PEOPLE YOUR FAMILY
. SO THIS IS AGAIN VERY
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE WE HAVE
APPROPRIATE ACCESS. TO
LIFESAVING PREVENTION FOR
CHILDREN. AND WHAT THAT THAT'S
WHY NOT ONLY OF COURSE. AM I
SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF IT MY
COLLEAGUES IN MY PROFESSION ARE
SO YOU DON'T LISTEN TO THIS ONE
PEDIATRICIAN HERE TO HAVE THIS
BE AMONG YOU. THE PEDIATRICIANS
OF CALIFORNIA STANFORD S.
PROGRESS THE BOARD. YOUNG PEOPLE
WANT THIS. YOUNG PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WATER BOARD PROVIDERS
THIS SB A SUCCESS AUTHORS
AUTHORIZES BALI ECONOMY THAT
THEY ARE CAPABLE OF CAPABLE OF
THE TEENS USE AXES ACT AS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL THAT WE NEED TO
REDUCE THE BARRIER VACCINATIONS
I STRICTLY ASPEN EITHER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
SENATOR GORGEOUS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT YOU'RE DOING A FINE
JOB TODAY I MIGHT ADD. OUR
COLLEAGUES. THIS IS CERTAINLY A
DIFFICULT ISSUE- BUT IF WE WERE
TO GO BACK IN TIME WHEN WE WERE
GOING TO THE FIRST YEAR OF
COATED- IN CERTAINLY INTO THE
SECOND WE WERE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IN
TERMS OF AXING POLICY. I
CONSULTED WITH MY FAMILY DOCTOR
AND CONSULT WITH MY FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. AND I PERSONALLY
BELIEVE THAT VACCINES WERE THE
BEST PATH FORWARD FOR ME AND MY
FAMILY IN SPECIFICALLY MY TWO
YOUNG BOYS AGE TEN AND EIGHT.
THIS BILL. I BELIEVE THAT WORK
IS GOING TO HAVE MANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. THE FIRST OF WHICH
WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE PARENT
AND WHAT IS THE LEGAL AGE OF
MAJORITY WHAT DOES THAT MEAN.
BECAUSE AS WE'VE HEARD BEFORE
THAT YOU CAN BE TWELVE YEARS OLD
TO GET CERTAIN- MEDICAL
TREATMENT WE'LL HAVE TO BE A
DIFFERENT AGE TO VOTE OR SERVE
IN THE MILITARY AND YET ANOTHER
AGE TO BUY TO BUY ALCOHOL OR
SMOKE CIGARETTES. SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN TWELVE AND TWENTY ONE IS
THE AGE OF MAJORITY IN
CALIFORNIA WE JUST CAN'T FIGURE
OUT WHICH ONE WE WANT. AND WHICH
ONES MOST APPLICABLE. BUT FOR
THIS PURPOSE FOR THIS PARTICULAR
BILL. MY CONCERN IS THAT WE
HEARD IN JUDICIARY PEOPLE CALL
IN WE ALSO HEARD FROM OUR STEAM
TO- PHYSICIAN ARE ALSO A MEMBER
OF THIS BODY. THAT THIS IS GOING
TO MAKE LIFE EASIER BECAUSE A
LOT OF TIMES THESE INDIVIDUALS
THESE CHILDREN CAN'T GET
PARENTAL PERMISSION BECAUSE
MAYBE THE PARENTS WORK OUTSIDE
THE AREA WHERE THEY'RE BUSY OR
TO SINGLE MOM WORKING TWO JOBS.
THAT ENTIRE SCENARIO CAN BE
RESOLVED ADMINISTRATIVELY. BY
HAVING A SIGN OFF PROGRAM THAT
AUTHORIZES THE PAIR TO STILL
MAKE THE DECISION IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD AND THE
CHILD BE BE GIVEN ACCESS TO THE
VACCINE. SO LET'S NOT KID
OURSELVES THAT BUT THIS IS THE
ONLY WAY FORWARD ON THIS ISSUE.
PARENTAL CONSENT CAN BE GIVEN
AND THEY CAN BE EXPEDITED IN
ADMINISTRATIVE FASHION BUT I
HAVEN'T HEARD US TALK TOO MUCH
ABOUT THAT. I'VE ALSO HEARD
THAT- THIS ISSUE IS ABOUT
FOLLOWING. EXISTING LEGISLATION
. WITH THAT IS THE RATIONALE.
IT'S HARD NOT TO IMAGINE THAT
EXISTING LEGISLATION WASN'T
DELIBERATELY PUT INTO INTO A
FACT FOR THE VERY PURPOSE OF
OPENING THE DOOR FOR
SUBSEQUENTLY LEGISLATION. SO I
HAVE I HAVE AN ABSOLUTE HORROR
TIME. TRYING TO RECONCILE THIS
BECAUSE IF WE CONTINUE DOWN THIS
PATH I IMAGINE A YEAR FROM NOW
OR TWO YEARS FROM NOW. THIS SAME
ISSUE OF TWELVE YEAR OLD CONSENT
WILL SOMEHOW FIND ITS WAY INTO
CLINICAL TRIALS. RIGHT NOW IT
HAS TO BE FTA APPROVED. BUT IN
TWO YEARS FROM NOW. IT'S ONLY A
MATTER TIME BEFORE CERTAIN
PHARMACEUTICAL POWERS IN
INTEREST WANTING TO- TO BUILD UP
A BODY OF SCHOLARSHIP IN A
CERTAIN AREA ARE GOING TO WANT
TO MAKE CERTAIN THE CLINICAL
TRIALS CAN BE ACHIEVED. BY THE
CONSENTING PRINCIPAL WHO HAPPENS
TO BE TWELVE YEARS OLD. AS A
PARENT. THIS IS DEEPLY TROUBLING
TO ME. N. AS A PARENT WHO
BELIEVES THAT VACCINES. I DON'T
THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT PATH
FORWARD BECAUSE I THINK YOU CAN
ACHIEVE THE MAJORITY OF WHAT.
YOUR CONSTITUENTS IN CALL INS
AND COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID THIS
CAN BE DONE ADMINISTRATIVELY. I
DON'T THINK WE SPEND ENOUGH TIME
ON ON ON THAT ON THAT ISSUE. AND
SO. I GUESS. I GUESS I WILL
CONCLUDE WITH THIS COLLEAGUES
THAT FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
PARENTS OR HAVE LEGAL
GUARDIANSHIP OVER CHILDREN YOU
HAVE CERTAIN RESPONSIBILITIES.
YOU ARE EXPECTED TO OVERSEE AND
TAKE AGENCY OF THAT MINOR. THIS
LAW IN THE ENTIRE CADRE OF
ASSOCIATED LAWS THAT ARE MAKING
LEGAL CONSENT THE H. TWELVE IS
DOING AWAY WITH ALL OF THAT. SO
AS A PARENT YOU HAVE FULL LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITY BUT YOU HAVE NO
PARENTAL AUTHORITY. THIS IS A
DANGEROUS PATH FORWARD IN AS
PARENTS OR THOSE WHO ARE
GRANDPARENTS IN THIS ROOM I
THINK YOU SHOULD LOOK UPON THIS
ON ON A PERSONAL LEVEL. WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS WILL MEAN
TODAY BUT TOMORROW AND IN. THE
YEARS TO COME. THANK YOU SIR
BARGES SENATOR MELENDEZ. I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES IN
GERMAN I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL- I YOU KNOW THERE WAS
A COMMENT MADE THAT- THAT THERE
IS NO MEDICAL REASON FOR THIS
NOT TO BE LAW AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY DISAGREE- JOHN
HOPKINS SINCE APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE HAVE REPORTED THERE
BEEN MORE THAN ONE THOUSAND
CASES OF MYOCARDITIS AND
PERICARDITIS CHILDREN HAPPENING
AFTER THE BACKS NATION I WOULD
SAY. THAT'S A VERY GOOD MEDICAL
REASON- NOT TO MENTION THE
MEDICAL REASON FOR WHEN A CHILD
MIGHT HAVE SOME UNDERLYING
MEDICAL ISSUE OR PERHAPS TAKING
SOME OTHER MEDICATION THAT
MIGHT- CAUSE AN ADVERSE EFFECT
AFTER GETTING A PARTICULAR
VACCINATION AND THAT MINOR CHILD
NOT TELLING THE PERSON
MINISTERING THE VACCINE IF
THEY'RE TAKING THAT MEDICATION
OR THAT THEY HAVE THAT FAMILY
HISTORY OR THAT THEY HAVE THAT
PARTICULAR MEDICAL CONDITION. IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A TWELVE
YEAR OLD I MEAN. YOU KNOW MANY
OF YOU IN HERE HAVE KIDS SOME OF
YOU STILL HAVE KIDS IN THE HOME
LIKE I DO AND YOU KNOW THE KIDS
THAT YOUNG I HAD DIFFICULTY
REMEMBERING A LOT OF THINGS LET
ALONE ANY PARTICULAR MEDICATION
OR MEDICAL- ILLNESS YOU KNOW
THAT THEY MAY HAVE THAT THEY
WOULD NEED TO DIVULGE. TO THE
PERSON ADMINISTERING THE
VACCINES. NOT TO MENTION IF THIS
MINOR CHILD GOES AND GETS THIS
VACCINATION. AND DOESN'T TELL
THEIR PARENTS HOW IN THE WORLD
AS A PARENT SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT SOMETHING IS
GOING WRONG AFTER GETTING THAT
BACKS THE NATION HOW WOULD A
PARENT KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT IT
IS CAUSED BY AND THEN KNOW HOW
TO SEEK THE PROPER MEDICAL CARE
PARTICULARLY IF AS MANY HAVE
POINTED OUT THERE ARE PARENTS
WHO ARE JUST TOO BUSY. TO TAKE
THEIR KIDS TO GET NEEDED WILL OF
THE PAYMENTS ARE BUSY AND
WORKING AND NOT THERE TO SEE
THAT THERE'S SOME SORT OF
ADVERSE REACTION. HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO HELP THEM IF THE
PARENTS DON'T KNOW THAT THE
CHILD GOT THE VACCINATION. HOW
WOULD THEY KNOW TO EVEN KEEP AN
EYE OUT FOR IT TO WATCH FOR IT.
THEY ARE AT THEIR SECOND JOB
MAYBE PERHAPS TELL AN OLDER
SIBLING OR THEIR CARETAKER. HEY
KEEP AN EYE OUT FOR ANY ANY OF
THESE SORTS OF SYMPTOMS IN MY
CHILD THEY WOULDN'T KNOW THAT.
THEY WOULDN'T KNOW THAT. AND I
THINK THAT IS UNFAIR. AND
UNREASONABLE. TO DO TO A CHILD
OR TO ANY PARENT OUT THERE HE
JUST WANTS TO KEEP THEIR CHILD
SAFE. IRRESPECTIVE OF WHETHER OR
NOT THEY BELIEVE IN ANY
PARTICULAR VACCINE BECAUSE
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS BEING ABOUT THE
COVERT VACCINE BUT THIS BILL
DOESN'T RELATE ONLY TO THE KOBE
VACCINE ALTHOUGH I THINK THAT'S
LARGELY WHAT HAS DOMINATED
PEOPLE'S MINDS. THIS POINT. I'M
THE OTHER ISSUE WITH THIS BILL
IS I'M NOT ENTIRELY SURE THAT
IT'S- LEGAL. D. NATIONAL
CHILDHOOD VACCINE INJURY ACT
STATES EACH HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
WHO ADMINISTERED- ADMINISTERS A
VACCINE SET FORTH IN THE VACCINE
INJURY TABLE SHALL PROVIDE TO
THE LEGAL REPRESENTATIVES OF ANY
CHILD OR TO ANY OTHER INDIVIDUAL
TO HIM SUCH. VAIDER INTENDS TO
ADMINISTER SUCH FAXING A COPY OF
THE VACCINE INFORMATION
STATEMENTS SUPPLEMENTED WITH
VISUAL PRESENTATIONS ARE ORAL
EXPLANATIONS IN APPROPRIATE
CASES AND IT HAS TO BE
ADMINISTERED PRIOR TO GIVING THE
VACCINE. SO IF YOU GIVE. A MINOR
THIS. VACCINATION AND YOU HAND
THEM THE BOOKLET OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT ADVERSE REACTIONS THAT
MAY TAKE PLACE. DO YOU TRUST
THAT THAT MINOR WILL REDUCE. DO
YOU TRUST THAT THAT MINOR WILL
GIVE IT TO AN ADULT IN THEIR
LIFE WHO MAY BE WATCHING OVER
THEM THAT THEY WILL GIVE IT TO
THEM. PROBABLY NOT. PARTICULARLY
IF THEIR PARENTS ARE THERE ARE
THEIR HEALTH OR THEIR THEIR
PROVIDER THEIR YOU KNOW
WHOEVER'STAKING CARE OF THEM.
DOESN'T EVEN KNOW THEY'RE
GETTING IT YOUR THIS PUTS
CHILDREN AT RISK BY NOW. THERE
ARE. PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM WHO
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT EVERY CHILD
SHOULD GET THIS VACCINE WEATHERS
THE COVERT VACCINE OR ANY OTHER.
I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I THINK
YOU'RE NOT LOOKING AT THE
REALITY OF THE SITUATION WHICH
IS THIS COULD ACTUALLY CAUSE.
VERY SERIOUS HARM TO CHILDREN
THERE IS A REASON THAT THERE IS
A DATABASE THAT TRACKS ADVERSE
REACTIONS TO VACCINATIONS NOT
JUST THE KOBE BAXEEN BUT ALL
VACCINATIONS THERE'S A REASON
FOR THAT THERE'S A REASON THERE
IS A FUND HAS BEEN SET UP. THAT
HAS PAID OUT NEARLY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. TO THOSE HAVE BEEN
INJURED OR- DIED. FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE VACCINE
ALMOST FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. WHY
IS THAT BECAUSE THESE THINGS DO
HAPPEN. LARGELY VACCINATIONS ARE
ADMINISTERED IN THERE ARE NO
SERIOUS SIDE EFFECTS BUT GUESS
WHAT THERE MANY OTHER INSTANCES
WHERE THERE ARE SO I AM ASKING
YOU. TO PLEASE CONSIDER THE
HEALTH OF THESE CHILDREN PLEASE
CONSIDER THAT YOU ARE PUTTING
PARENTS IN A TERRIBLE SITUATION
WHERE THEY WOULD HAVE NO IDEA
THAT THEIR CHILD MIGHT BE HAVING
SOME SORT OF REACTION TO THIS
VACCINE AND HAVE NO ABILITY TO
HELP THEM BECAUSE THEY DON'T
EVEN KNOW THAT IT'S GOING ON. I
URGE YOU KNOW ABOUT. THANK YOU
SIR MELENDEZ CENTER OTOBO. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
TAKING A FULL BREATH BECAUSE I
WANT MY ADRENALINE TO COME DOWN
MY HEART'S BEATING SO FAST RIGHT
NOW. AND I WE HAD SOME NOTES
BECAUSE I KNEW THAT I WOULD GET
REALLY RILED UP IN I WANT TO BE
FRONTAL LOBE THINKING AND NOT
PRIMAL IN MY BRAIN OF TRYING TO
EXPRESS MY THOUGHTS THIS MORNING
TO MY COLLEAGUES. WHO I.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY RESPECT. WHILE I
BELIEVE THAT AXES ARE AN
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH TOOL
THAT WE HAVE. AND ENCOURAGE ALL
TO CONSULT WITH THEIR DOCTORS
AND CONSIDER GETTING VACCINATED.
I RISE TODAY IS APPARENT WITH
STRONG CONCERNS ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS MEASURE.
THIS BILL WOULD EMPOWER
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS OF
CHILDREN TO CONSENT TO MEDICAL
TREATMENT THAT THEY LIKELY KNOW
LITTLE ABOUT WITHOUT THE
GUIDANCE OR KNOWLEDGE OF A CARE
GIVER OR PARENTS. AT TWELVE
YEARS OF AGE I TELL THE BRAIN IS
STILL FORMING AND THEIR
REASONING SKILLS ARE NOT ALWAYS
FULLY DEVELOPED. I THINK WE CAN
ALL AGREE ON THAT. A MINOR. IS
ANY PERSON BELOW THE AGE OF
ADULTHOOD WHO IS STILL LEGALLY
UNDER THE AUTHORITY AND
SUPERVISION OF THEIR PARENTS. DO
WE HEAR THAT A MINOR. LEGAL
DEFINITION. AN EMANCIPATED MINOR
IS ONE WHO HAS PROVEN TO THE
COURT THAT THEY ARE MATURE
ENOUGH TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS. OWN DECISIONS MANAGE
THEIR FINANCES AND THAT
EMANCIPATION IS THE BEST PATH
FOR THEM. PARENTS AND GUARDIANS
KNOW THEIR CHILDREN BEST. WHICH
IS WHY THEY ARE CURRENTLY
REQUIRED TO FURNISH INFORMATION
ABOUT THE CHILD'S MEDICAL
HISTORY. RYER ALLERGIC REACTIONS
AND OVERALL WILL BE. PERSONALLY
I DO KNOW IS ARE ALLERGIC TO
PENICILLIN BECAUSE OF THAT
REACTION THAT HAS A BABY. UNTIL
MY MOM TOLD ME LATER ON AS AN
ADULT. PARENTS ARE ALSO REQUIRED
BY FEDERAL LAW TO BE PROVIDED
WITH SIGNIFICANT PAPERWORK
REGARDING SIDE EFFECTS TO EACH
VACCINE. HOW TO DETECT SIGNS OF
ADVERSE REACTION IN CHILDREN ANY
EMERGENCY PROTOCOLS. UNDER THIS
BILL IF A MINOR CHILD CONSENTS
TO VACCINATION WITHOUT PARENTAL
KNOWLEDGE AND HAVE A REACTION
THE PARENT MAY NOT RECOGNIZE THE
VACCINE REACTION SYMPTOMS WHICH
CAN PUT THE CHILD AT FURTHER
RISK. ALL OF THESE REASONS WHY
VACCINE DECISIONS SHOULD BE MADE
BETWEEN PARENTS. CHILDREN AND A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. THIS BILL
IS ONE OF MANY THAT WE HAVE SEEN
SEEKING TO REMOVE THE IMPORTANT
ROLE OF. THANKS. AS A STRONG
BELIEVER IN THE POWER OF THE
FAMILY UNIT. I URGE ALL OF US TO
CONSIDER THE BROADER
IMPLICATIONS OF THE DECISIONS WE
MAKE HERE. AS WE ARE MAKING
DECISIONS THAT EMPOWER HEALTHY
FAMILIES TO MAKE THE DECISIONS
THAT ARE BEST FOR THEIR FAMILIES
OR WE ARE MANDATING FROM THE TOP
DOWN WHAT WE THINK IS BEST. I'M
GOING TO GO STRAIGHT RIGHT NOW
AND I'M GOING OFF THE HEART
RIGHT NOW. I'VE BEEN HERE ONLY.
A YEAR AND A HALF. NOT VERY LONG. BUT I'VE SEEN AND I'VE BEEN
LISTENING CAREFULLY TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN STATING
HERE. WHAT MOTIVATES YOUR BILLS
WHAT MORE WHAT'S IN YOUR HEART
AND SOMETIMES WHAT MOTIVATES
YOUR BILLS. SOMETIMES WE GET
MYOPIC WITH TICKET WE FOCUS ON
ONE PARTICULAR BUILT ON THE
MERITS OF THAT BILL. AND I CAN
SEE THAT SOMETIMES WE VOTE
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS WARM AND FUZZY
IT'S SOMETHING THAT OKAY IT
SOUNDS REALLY GOOD. BUT HERE'S
THE THING COLLEAGUES. COMING
FROM OUT THERE AND TO HEAR.
SOMETIMES THE IMPLICATIONS OF
THE BILLS THAT WE HAVE. HAVE AN
IMPACT THAT DOESN'T COME RIGHT
AWAY BECOMES TEN TWENTY THIRTY
FORTY YEARS FROM NOW. AND WHAT
DO I MEAN BY THAT. I HEARD ONCE
FOR ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES THAT WE
CAN'T LEGISLATE VALUES. BUT LET
ME REASSURE YOU THAT WHAT WE
LEGISLATIVE BECOMES OUR VALUES
OR A REFLECTION OF THE VALUES
THAT SOME OF US HAVE. A VOTE
TODAY ON THIS BILL. IS NOT DOES
NOT KNOW ABOUT ME JUST CLARIFY A
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL DOES NOT
IMPLICATE THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
BELIEVE IN VACCINATION. IT'S NOT
A MATTER OF COST BECAUSE IT'S
READILY ACCESSIBLE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR HAS
MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN. FOR ANYONE TO HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO MAKE THAT CHOICE.
BUT A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL TODAY
. BEANS THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT
THE PARENT FUNDAMENTALLY OR THE
CARE GIVER FUNDAMENTALLY. HAS
THE ABILITY TO SEEK THE
RESOURCES. AND MAKE DECISIONS
THAT IS BEST FOR THEIR CHILD IN
THEIR FAMILY. WE ARE EMPOWERING
THEM NOT DISENFRANCHISES IN A
PARENT OR A FAMILY. THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL UNIT OF ANY SOCIETY
. WE KNOW WE KNOW THAT HEALTHY
FAMILIES ARE FUNDAMENTAL. TO A
HEALTHY COMMUNITY HEALTHY
SOCIETY HELP THE STATE AND HELP
THE COUNTRY. WE KNOW THAT. BUT
WE PASSED LEGISLATION WHAT WE
TAKE AWAY THE PARENTS ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR CHILD'S
UPBRINGING. WELL BEING. WHAT
VALUES ARE YOU PROMOTING AND
CONVEY. THAT'S WHAT I KNOW BOARD
OR A YES VOTE WOULD MEAN ON THIS
. NOT THE FACT THAT THE VACCINES
ARE NOT AVAILABLE BECAUSE THEY
ARE. TO EVERYONE AND ANYONE WHO
CHOOSES TO HELP THEM. THE OTHER
THING I WANTED TO MENTION. IS
THAT MOVING FORWARD. THE NOTION
OF A PRECEDENCE BECAUSE WE'VE
DONE IT BEFORE REFINERS COULD
GET A VACCINE. DOZEN MAKES IT SO
THAT THIS IS OKAY. THAT JUST
MAKES IT THAT WERE FURTHERING
FOR THE STRIPPING AWAY CHIPPING
AWAY. AT A PARENT'S
RESPONSIBILITY AND ABILITY TO
PAY. I HATE TO SAY THIS. BUT
GOVERNMENT. CAN ONLY PROVIDE THE
FRAMEWORK IN WHICH PEOPLE CAN
CHOOSE TO PURSUE LIFE LIBERTY
AND HAPPINESS. WHEN WE START
OVER REACHING AND MANDATING. AND
TELLING PEOPLE WHAT THEY CAN AND
CANNOT DO YOU. COLLEAGUES LET'S
RETHINK FOR WE'RE GOING. WHERE
ARE HER VALUES PUSHING US TO THE
POINT WHERE WE SAY PARENTS ARE
NO LONGER NECESSARY. JUST A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO. THE
SACRAMENTO BEE HAD AN ARTICLE
ABOUT THE READING SCORES OF
CALIFORNIA. BEING AT THE VERY
BOTTOM ACROSS THE STATE. IN
COMPARISON TO ACROSS THE STATE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT ONE OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT THEY HAD ON
THAT ARTICLE WHAT WOULD MAKE AN
IMPACT IN A DIFFERENCE AND NOT.
PERRANCE ENGAGEMENT. PARENT
ENGAGEMENT WOULD MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT IN OUR
READING SCORES. SO SEE AS A BODY
TODAY. WELL WE EMPOWER PARENTS
WITH RESOURCES AND THE ABILITY
THE AUTONOMY TO MAKE DECISIONS
AND BRING HARMONY TO THAT FAMILY
. OR WILL THIS SHIPPED OUT RIGHT
AWAY. COLLEAGUES. B. VISIONARIES
YOUR LEGISLATION BEING VISIONARY
IN THE WAY THAT YOUR VALUES WILL
BE MANIFESTED BASED ON
LEGISLATION MOVING FORWARD
TWENTY THIRTY AND FORTY YEARS
FROM NOW. ONCE AGAIN. I KNOW
VOTE TODAY DOES NOT MEAN YOUR
ENTIRE BACKSEAT IT JUST MEANS
THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT. PARENT
INVOLVEMENT AND ENGAGEMENT IS
CRUCIAL IN MAKING AN IMPACT IN A
DIFFERENCE IN A CHILD'S LIFE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER OCHO BOGUS SENATOR
COM LONGER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW I WAS NOT
EXPECTING TO RAISE MY MICROPHONE
ON THIS BILL I WASN'T EVEN
EXPECTING IT TO COME UP- BUT
I'VE BEEN LISTENING. TWO THE
COMMENTS ON THE FLOOR. AND I
HAVE BEEN THINKING ABOUT THEM.
AS A PARENT AND LISTENING TO ALL
OF THE ONES WHO HAVE RAISED
THEIR MICROPHONE OR WHO HAVE
SHARED- YOU KNOW THEIR THOUGHTS
ON THIS LEGISLATION AND WHERE WE
ARE IN THIS TIME AS A PARENT OR
AS A GUARDIAN. AND I'M GOING TO
JUST BE HONEST WITH YOU YOU KNOW
AS A PARENT. I WANT TO HAVE
TOTAL CONTROL. OVER EVERYTHING
IN MY HOUSEHOLD. INCLUDING MY
CHILDREN. I WANT THEM TO ASK ME
ALL KINDS OF QUESTIONS I WANT TO
BE THE ONE GIVING THEM ALL OF
THE ANSWERS I WANT ALL OF THE
ANSWERS TO BE CORRECT AND WHEN
THEY ARE NOT I WANT TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GO BACK AND FIND THE
RIGHT ANSWER AND COME BACK. AND
GIVE IT TO THEM. THAT IS A
FANTASY. THAT IS A FANTASY. I
HAVE NOT BEEN THINKING ABOUT
VACCINES IN THE CONTEXT OF EIGHT
SIX SIX I HAVE TO TELL YOU. AND
I AM NOT THINKING ABOUT OTHER
PARENTS LIKE ME. WHO HAVE THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THEIR CHILDREN
AT HEART. I AM THINKING ABOUT
OTHER PARENTS AND GUARDIANS OUT
THERE WHO DO NOT. WHO ARE ABSENT
WHO ARE NEGLECTFUL WHO ARE
ABUSIVE WHO ARE HARMFUL. IN FACT
I WAS THINKING ABOUT. THE PARENT
ARRESTED THIS WEEK FOR KILLING
HER CHILDREN. I WAS THINKING
ABOUT PARENTS WHO ARE ANTI GAY
WHO HAVE A CHILD WHO IS L. G. B.
T. Q. I. A. AND HOW THEY PUNISH.
THEM FOR BEING GAY REFUSE TO
SHARE INFORMATION OR ACCESS TO
RESOURCES OR SUPPORT OR TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY EXIST.
NONE OF THAT HAS ANYTHING TO DO
WITH VACCINES FOR SURE. BUT IT
DOES ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE
ALL KINDS OF PARENTS. OUT THERE
. AND SOME ARE AMAZING. ALL OF
US FAIL. MANY OF US FAIL WITH
REALLY GREAT INTENTIONS AT HEART
. AND THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE
NOT. LOOKING OUT FOR THE WELL
BEING OF THE CHILDREN IN THEIR
LIVES. I COMPLETELY AGREE
PARENTAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
LEGAL AUTHORITY. THERE SHOULD BE
GREATER CONNECTIVITY BECAUSE I
CAN TELL YOU SO MANY EXAMPLES OF
WHY I FEEL LIKE HOW AM I
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF THIS AND
THE CHALLENGES WANTS TO DO THE
WHOLE THING BUT MAYBE I'M JUST
CAUGHT UP IN THE MADNESS OF
HAVING A TEENAGER AT HOME. BUT I
DO THINK WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO LEGISLATE
SAFETY. AND I THINK WE HAVE TO
BE HONEST ABOUT ALL KINDS OF
PARENTS. THAT ARE OUT HERE. AND
SOME REALLY DO NEED LEGISLATIVE
CIRCUMVENTION LIKE THIS I'LL
REPHRASE THAT THE PARENTS MIGHT
NOT NEED IT BUT THE CHILDREN
DESERVE IT BECAUSE I WILL TELL
YOU THIS YOUNG PEOPLE KNOW. WHEN
THEY ARE IN TROUBLE THEY KNOW
WHEN THEY ARE IN HARM'S WAY THEY
KNOW THAT THEY ARE WITH A PARENT
OR GUARDIAN THAT IS NOT LOVING
THEM. AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES THAT WE- NO THEY
SHOULD HAVE TO HELP THEM
NAVIGATE THROUGH THEIR YOUNG
LIFE SAFELY. AND WHEN IT COMES
TO HAVING ACCESS TO MEDICINE
THAT WILL KEEP YOU SAFE JUST
LIKE IT WHEN IT COMES TO HAVING
ACCESS TO RESOURCES THAT WILL
KEEP YOU ALIVE THAT WILL PROTECT
YOU WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
TALK ABOUT THOSE INSTANCES AND
FIND A WAY TO CREATE POLICY THAT
WILL HELP THOSE CHILDREN. SO I
AM NOT THINKING ABOUT EIGHT SIX
SIX IN THE CONTEXT OF MY FAMILY
. BECAUSE WE DO HAVE SPACE AT
THE TABLE FOR HONEST
UNCOMFORTABLE OPEN DISCUSSIONS
WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO CREATE A PATH WHERE THE
WHOLE FAMILY IS ON BOARD. I'M
NOT THINKING ABOUT THOSE
FAMILIES I'M THINKING ABOUT
THOSE FAMILIES WHERE CHILDREN
ARE AT RISK AND THE PARENT OR
GUARDIAN THAT SHOULD BE LOOKING
OUT FOR THEM IS NOT. IS
INTENTIONALLY NOT. AND HOW DO WE
HELP THEM. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB EIGHT SIX
AND- THANK YOU CENTER COME
LONGER SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED SENATOR
WIENER YOU MAY CLOSE. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR- THE
DEBATE I'D APPRECIATE IT I DO
JUST WANT TO SAY ONE THING WITH
ALL RESPECT. THIS ISN'T THIS IS
NOT A WARM AND FUZZY BILL. WE
HAVE BILLS ON THIS FLOOR WE
COOPER MY NAME A FEW. NUMBER YOU
KNOW WE'VE ALL PROBABLY AT ONE
POINT OR ANOTHER AUTHORED A
BILL. THAT IS WARM AND FUZZY
THAT IS JUST LIKE A FEEL GOOD.
BILL YOU KNOW IT'S A GOOD BILL
BUT IS NOT GOING TO LIKE YOU
KNOW. CHANGE THE WORLD. THIS IS
NOT ONE OF THOSE BILLS. WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT A TEENAGER. WHO IS
EITHER BEING BLOCKED BY THEIR
PARENT FROM PROTECTING THEIR
HEALTH. OR IS BEING NEGLECTED OR
ABUSED AND CAN PROTECT THEIR
HEALTH. WHEN A TEENAGER IS
SIMPLY SAYING. I HAVE I'M A
TEENAGER WHO'S IMMUNO
COMPROMISED AND DOESN'T WANT TO
END UP ON A VENTILATOR. A
TEENAGER WHO DOESN'T WANT TO GET
THE MONTHS AND BECOME STERILE.
PARENTS OFTEN BECOME STERILE THE
KIDS GOING TO BE STERILE FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES. A KID WHO
GOD FOR BID POLIO COMES BACK TO
THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE AS I MET IT
IS CIRCULATING IN THE WORLD. IF
POLIO COMES BACK. WHO DOESN'T
WANT TO BE PARA PARALYZED.
BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS SPEND TOO
MUCH TIME ON YOUTUBE OR FOX NEWS
. AND IS PROVIDING THE KIDS ARE
GETTING VACCINATED. IT'S ABOUT
THOSE KIDS BEING ABLE TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN HEALTH. WE'VE HEARD
SOME PARADES OF HORRIBLE'S TODAY
ABOUT FDA CLINICAL TRIALS WHICH
ISN'T EVEN A QUESTION OF STATE
LAW THAT FEDERAL LAW WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT MACRO DATA SAID SIDE
EFFECTS. BUT WE HAVE THAT OTHER
PARADE OF HORRIBLE'S ABOUT KIDS
ACTUALLY GETTING SICK AND DYING
NOT SYSTEM CODED BUT OTHER
DISEASES THAT ARE 1100% PER
PERCENT PREVENTABLE. BUT FOR THE
PARENT NOT ALLOWING THE KID TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES. WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT HEALTH HISTORY BUT NO KID
KNOWS OUR HEALTH HISTORY A LOT
OF KIDS DO KNOW THEIR HEALTH
HISTORY AND THEY KNOW WHAT THE
HELL'S THERE TAKING AND DOCTORS
OR PHARMACISTS OR OTHER HEALH
CARE PROFESSIONALS THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH
INTENSIVE TRAINING KNOWING WHAT
QUESTIONS TO ASK WHAT WARNING
SIGNS TO LOOK FOR. AND HOW TO
MAKE DECISIONS ON WHO CAN GIVE
INFORMED CONSENT. THESE ARE
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS. NOT
JUST RANDOM PEOPLE. THANK HIGHS
I DISMISSED SAY OF COURSE WE
WANT PARENTS TO BE INVOLVED IN
THEIR KIDS HEALTH CARE.
ABSOLUTELY WE WANT PARENTS TO BE
INVOLVED. OF COURSE WE WANT KIDS
TO FEEL COMFORTABLE TALKING TO
THEIR PARENTS ABOUT VACCINATION-
OR HUNDREDS OF OTHER IMPORTANT
ISSUES IN LIFE WE ABSOLUTELY
WANT THAT. BUT AS A SENATOR FROM
LOS ANGELES VERY ELOQUENTLY
STATED. THAT'S NOT THE REALITY
OF THE WORLD. FOR EVERY CHILD.
AND THERE ARE FAR TOO MANY
CHILDREN WHO CAN'T TALK TO THEIR
PARENTS FOR WHATEVER REASON.
WHERE THEY FEAR THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ABUSED AND THEY TALK
TO THEIR PARENTS ABOUT IT.
WHETHER PARENTS JUST WON'T
LISTEN TO THEM. AND FOR THOSE
KIDS. THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PROTECT THEIR OWN HEALTH THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT AND
THAT'S ALL. THAT IT'S ABOUT. FOR
VACCINES THAT THE FDA HAS
DETERMINED. ARE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE. I'M AT THE CDC HAS
DETERMINED AS APPROPRIATE FOR
THIS AGE GROUP I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AIBO. THANK YOU SIR
WHERE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA. ATKINS
AYE BATES BAKER HI FORGES NO
BRADFORD I CABALLERO CORTESE I
DALY. DODD AYE THEY'RE AWESOME
AYE EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE
WESA NO FURTADO NO JONES NO
KAMLAGER I LAYERED. I LEYVA.
LIMÓN MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ NO MAN
. NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN NO A CHOI
BOGUE NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER AYE STERN.
AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI I WIENER
AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN. ARCHULETA BASS
CABALLERO. DALLY GROWTH. LEYVA
LIMÓN I. MAN ROTH RUBIO STERN.
WELL FROM. I TWENTY ONE KNOWS IS
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR
RUBIO WILL BE PRESENTING SENATE
RESOLUTION. EIGHTY SEVEN.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO THE
DAY OF THE TEACHER JENNIFER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE HAVE OUR
ATTENTION TO THE FLOOR PLEASE.
CENTER RUBIO YOU'RE RECOGNIZED I
HAD TO BE A TEACHER HERE AND ASK
MR DOT TO SIT DOWN IN HIS PAST
THANK YOU MISTER DOT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
BUSINESS AND A RESOLUTION TO PUT
PAINT PROPANE MAY ELEVEN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS THE DATE OF THE
TEACHER. TEACHERS ARE EVERYDAY
HEROES IN MY BOX WE HAVE
DEDICATED THEIR- WHO HAVE
DEDICATED. SIX MONTHS SORRY THE
DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO TEACH
OUR CHILDREN. I HAVE SEEN
FIRSTHAND AS A TEACHER JUST THE
WONDERFUL THINGS THAT THEY DO
AND HOW THEY CARE FOR OUR
CHILDREN. OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THEIR COMMITMENT TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS THRIVE. DESPITE
THEIR DEEP INVOLVEMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND A LOT OF THEIR
PERSONAL FINANCIAL INVESTMENT
FROM BUYING SHOES AND CLOTHING
AND BOOKS AND MAKING SURE THAT
SOMETIMES OUR FAD. AS I'VE DONE
MYSELF IN THE PAST SOMETIMES I
BELIEVE THEY DON'T GET THE
RECOGNITION THEY DESERVE. WE
ALLOW THEM TO EDUCATE OUR MOST
PRECIOUS LITTLE HUMANS. AND THEY
PLAY SO MANY DIFFERENT ROLES IN
THE CLASSROOM THAT ARE NOT IN
THE JOB DESCRIPTION THEIR
COUNSELORS THERE PERRANCE. ARE
YOU KNOW THEY'RE THE BEST
FRIENDS AND AGAIN THEY INVEST SO
MUCH OF THEIR PERSONAL TIME. AND
EFFORT IN MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE WELL ROUNDED. LITTLE
CHILDREN. EACH HAVE TO RE LAW
AND- EFFECTS ON SO MANY
CHILDREN. AND SURVEYS SHOW THAT
TEACHERS. STUDENTS CONFIDENCE
AND MOST STUDENTS ALSO SAY THAT
IT WAS A TEACHER WHO INSPIRED
THEM TO DO GREAT THINGS IN LIFE.
FOR ALL OUR TEACHERS FOR
EVERYTHING THAT THEY DO FOR OUR
SCHOOLS OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE
STATE WE NEED TO SHOW THEM OUR
APPRECIATION. AND RESPECT ON
THIS DAY OF THE TEACHER THANK
YOU KNOW I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON SR EIGHTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU CENTER RUBIO MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON SR
EIGHTY SEVEN ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SENATOR NIELSEN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THIS PRESENT LIGHT
IS ON THE SENATE. I RISE TO
KNOWLEDGE. MRS CROSBY. HIGH
SCHOOL ENGLISH TEACHER. TAUGHT
ME ENGLISH AND REVERENCE FOR
LANGUAGE. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
AS A MENTOR. WHO MADE A
DIFFERENCE IN MY LIFE EVEN TO
THIS VERY DAY. ONE OF MY FORMER
STAFF AND I. KID SOMETIMES ABOUT
THIS BEING A MRS CROSBY MOMENT.
SHE MAINTAINS THE DISCIPLINE AND
THE CLASSROOM. BUT SHE DELIVERED
A MESSAGE THAT WAS LASTING AND
WAY BEYOND. JUST ENGLISH INDEED
OUR TEACHERS HAVE A GREAT VALUE
. MY GRANDFATHER TAUGHT FOR
FORTY TWO YEARS. IN MANY SCHOOLS
ENDED UP IN HIGH SCHOOL FRESNO.
FORTY TWO YEARS OF DEDICATION
AND I REMEMBER GOING AROUND WITH
MY GRANDFATHER. AND HAVING
PEOPLE COME UP TO HIM. THAT'S A
MISTER HUDSON YOU MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN MY LIFE I REMEMBER
YOU. AND I TRY TO DO THAT MYSELF
THE KNOWLEDGE THOSE WHO HAD A
BIG IMPACT. ON MY LIFE. THE
PARENTS IS WE'VE DEBATED HERE
ARE SACRED TRUST. BUT WE ALSO
PLACE OUR TRUST IN OUR- AND
INDEED THEY DESERVE OUR SUPPORT
I URGE AND I'VE- THANK YOU
CENTER NELSON MEMBERS IF WE CAN
TAKE OUR CONVERSATIONS DOWN A
COUPLE NOTCHES SO WE CAN HEAR
THE FLOOR PRESENTATIONS PLEASE.
CENTER LAYERED YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS AS NOT JUST
SOMEONE WHO WAS MOVED BY
TEACHERS BUT SOMEONE WHO IS THE
SON OF TWO TEACHERS WHO HAD
FIFTY YEARS BETWEEN THEM AND
EDUCATION. AND I HAVE THIS
EXPERIENCE IT TOO ONE IS A SINCE
I'VE BEEN IN SACRAMENTO THREE
TIMES SOMEBODY HAS WALKED UP TO
ME. AND SAID TO YOUR DAD REALLY
MADE A DIFFERENCE IN MY LIFE
THERE WAS SOMEBODY THAT HE
TAUGHT TO SWIM. THERE WAS
SOMEBODY THAT HE ACTUALLY GOT A
BASKETBALL SCHOLARSHIP AND CAME
TO SACRAMENTO AND LATER BECAME A
CABINET SECRETARY IRONICALLY.
AND VERY WELCOMING- THAT JUST HE
MADE A DIFFERENCE DAY TO DAY IN
THEIR LIFE. AND A FEW YEARS AGO
I WAS IN- THE SENATOR FROM
NAPA'S DISTRICT IN MY HOME TOWN.
GOING TO A HIGH SCHOOL REUNION
AND I WENT AND I WAS GOING TO
HELP THEM SET UP IN THE ROOM.
AND THEY SAID WE CAN'T DO IT THE
PREVIOUS GROUP IS IN THERE
THEY'RE NOT OUT YET AND I SAID
WHO ARE THERE AND THEY'RE THE
PEOPLE. THAT GRADUATED FROM JOHN
SWETT HIGH SCHOOL IN CROCKETT
BETWEEN NINETEEN FIFTY TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY EXACTLY. THE
GROUP WHEN MY FATHER HAD BEEN A
TEACHER A COACH AND A PRINCIPAL.
SO BEING AT AN ELECTED OFFICIAL
I JUST BARGED IN THIS GROUP
UNINVITED. AND BECAME A
CELEBRITY- IT BECAUSE MY DAD
WALKED SOMEBODY OUT OF A ROOM
WHEN SHE WAS ABOUT TO FAIL A
TEST AND GAVE HER A PEP TALK AND
SHE CAME BACK IN AND- PASS THE
CLASS. HIKVISION I JUST HAD
STORY AFTER STORY LIKE THAT
THERE WAS EVEN SOMEBODY THAT WAS
IN THE CLASS OF THAT CABINET
SECRETARIES AND THEY SAID YOU
KNOW HE REALLY MENTORED THAT GUY
THAT BECAME A CABINET SECRETARY
BEING A CABINET SECRETARY IS A
BIG DEAL. AND I SAID WELL I KNOW
BUT I DIDN'T TELL HIM WHAT I DID
FOR A LIVING AT THE TIME BECAUSE
FOR THE FIRST TIME. IN TWENTY
FIVE YEARS I WAS ROUGHLY IT'S
KID AND I WAS ENJOYING THE FACT
THAT HE MADE A FUNDAMENTAL
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES AS
A TEACHER SO. WE HONOR TEACHERS
. I DISLIKE MY FOR. AND I THINK
OF THEY DO. DIDN'T ALLOW. OF
BOTCH. IT JUST MADE A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THIS RESOLUTION IS
ABOUT AND WE SHOULD HONOR
EVERYBODY THAT DOES THAT. AND I
AM PLEASED TO STAND UP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU CENTER
LAYERED ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER PAN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT CENTERS I TO RIGHTS A
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION I WANNA THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM BALDWIN PARK FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD- NO TEACHERS
NOT ONLY. YOU KNOW WHAT BY%
DEFINITION TEACHERS TEACH AND
CERTAINLY EDUCATION IS VERY
IMPORTANT BUT WE ALSO KNOW FOR
YOU. HAVING AN ADULT FIGURE IN
THEIR LIFE WHO CARES ABOUT THEM
SO VERY IMPORTANT AND WELL
CERTAINLY- IN MOST CASES THAT IS
THEIR PARENTS. OFF IT ALSO
BECOMES OUR TEACHERS AS WELL.
AND TEACHERS SO TEACHERS PLAY A
ROLE BEYOND JUST SIMPLY
EDUCATING OUR YOUTH THEY ARE
ALSO ROLE MODELS THEY ARE ALSO
MENTORS- THERE GUY THEIR GUY FOR
USE. AND WE NEED TO RESPECT THAT
ROLE AS WELL ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE
WATCHING LEGISLATION ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ACTUALLY CONSTRAINING
TEACHERS FROM BEING ABLE TO
SERVE IN THOSE ROLES
PARTICULARLY FOR YOUTH. WHO WHO
WHO WHO ARE MORE DISADVANTAGED
TO MAYBE LGBT Q. AT SARAH THIS
IS WHAT WE NEED TO BE SURE WE-
BOTH RECOGNIZE HONOR SEIZURES
BUT ALSO. PROVIDE THAT RESPECT
TO TEACHERS THAT THEY DESERVE
AND THE RESPECT THAT THEY NEED
TO BE SURE THEY CAN REALLY PLAY
A FULL ROLE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
THE LIVES OF OUR CHILDREN. I
SUSPECT THE S. ONE I DON'T THINK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED SENATOR WESSEL. THANK
YOU I ALSO RISE TO SUPPORTIVE
SORRY SEVEN AND JUST THE SPIRIT
OF GRATITUDE TO ALL THE TEACHERS
I HAD AN IMPACT IN MY LIFE I'D
LIKE TO SHARE THE NAMES OF A FEW
I'M JUST LIKE MY COLLEAGUE GET
OVER HERE I THOUGHT I THOUGHT
THAT WAS VERY CLASSY. AND YOU
KNOW I WENT TO CATHOLIC SCHOOL
THERE WAS A NON IN PARTICULAR
THE NAME SISTER MYRA THAT
RELEASED BY OUR INSPIRED ME TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT SCIENCE. AND IN
HIGH SCHOOL- A TEACHER THAT I
HAD A HISTORY TEACHER AT NESTLE
STEALS ACTUALLY TAUGHT ME TO
HAVE PRIDE IN MY ETHNICITY AND
MY A CULTURE AND WHERE I CAME
FROM THAT'S NOT ALWAYS YOU SEE
THAT AND TEACHERS THAT TRY TO BE
CON. IN STUDENTS. OUT OF THEIR
ORIGINS AND AT POINT LOMA HIGH
SCHOOL JOIN ROUTE WOODWARD THE
ME SO INTERESTED IN LITERATURE.
AND I NEVER FORGOT THE
CONTRIBUTION SHE MADE I STILL
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH MY ONE
OF MY OTHER TEACHERS FROM POINT
LOMA. LARRY ZEIGER. THAT IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR
FEATURES IN THE HISTORY OF POINT
WHEN MY SCHOOL BUT STILL- GUIDES
HIS STUDENTS FROM MANY MANY
YEARS PASSED AND HE- GOT ME MORE
INTERESTED IN DRAMA AND MUSIC.
AND THE ARTS. MARTHA MAKE CLEAR-
OUR LADY'S SCHOOL ALSO- AMBER
SHE TAUGHT US JOHN DENVER SONGS-
AND SHE WE WOULD SING- ALMOST
EVERY WEEK I STILL REMEMBER ALL
THOSE SONGS FROM THE THIRD GRADE
. AND SOME JOHN DENVER FAN
THANKS TO HER. AND ANY BRADFORD
BURNS AT UCLA HISTORY PROFESSOR
BUT JUST THROUGH HIS DYNAMIC
STYLE JUST GOT ME SO INTERESTED
IN LEARNING MORE ABOUT HISTORY
JUST WONDERFUL PEOPLE THAT CARE
SO MUCH ABOUT THEIR STUDENTS AND
THIS IS A TIME FOR US TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE THE
WONDERFUL CONTRIBUTIONS THEY
MAKE TO OUR STATE. THANK YOU SIR
HUESO ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO BE RECOGNIZED. SEEING NONE
CENTER RUBIO YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- YES AND
I JUST WANT TO ASK THAT TEACHERS
HAVE TOUCHED EVERYONE FROM THIS
FLOOR THE STATE IN OUR COUNTRY
AND WE ALL HOLD GRATITUDE TO ALL
THOSE TEACHERS THAT HAD PATIENTS
AND MENTORED US AND TALK TO US
AND I WANNA THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FROM SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO ABSENT
A CRUISE FOR THEIR PERSONAL
STORIES AND CONNECTIONS TO
TEACHERS AND- TO ALL THE
TEACHERS LISTENING OUT THERE WE
VALUE WE APPRECIATE YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE DONE WITH THAT. AND
TONIGHT FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA ATKINS AYE BATES BAKER
I FOR JUST AYE BRADFORD AYE
BYRON AYE FOR. AYE DALLY DODD
FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG
AYE WESSEL AYE FURTADO AYE JONES
FIVE KAMLAGER. I LAYERED I LEYVA
AYE THE MON. I MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S AYE MIN. NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN AYE A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. I STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI MY COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK.
HIGHS THIRTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
WERE GOING UP MOVING ON TO THE
CONSENT FACT A- TWO ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PULLED IS THERE ANY OTHER
ITEMS THAT MEMBERS WOULD WISH TO
PULL FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TEN TWENTY FOUR ELEVEN
FIFTY NINE FOURTEEN OR. FIVE
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR
EIGHT NINETY NINE NINE FORTY
NINE NINE EIGHTY FIVE TEN FIFTY
ONE TEN FIFTY SEVEN ELEVEN
THIRTY FOUR ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE TWELVE THIRTY
SEVEN FOURTEEN OH THREE FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY NINE FOURTEEN
NINETY THREE FOURTEEN NINETY
NINE AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION IS A NINETY SEVEN AND
NINETY EIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA. ATKINS AYE
BATES COOPER. FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I FOR
TESTING I DALY. DODD FIVE
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I WROTE HERTZBERG AYE
WESSEL AYE FURTADO AYE JONES I
KAMLAGER. I LAYERED I LEYVA.
LIMÓN I MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ FIVE
MILLION NEWMAN I NIELSEN AYE A
SHOW OF BOTH HI PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO HI
SKINNER AYE STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI WHITE HOUSE MEETING AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARCHULETA. BASS
BAKER I. DALLY GROVE LEYVA. I
MEN WILK ALL RIGHT HIGHS THIRTY
FOUR KNOWS ZERO MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE BACK TO
PRIVILEGES ON THE FLOOR. AND I
THINK WE HAVE ONE MEMBER WISHING
TO BE RECOGNIZED UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR CENTER
BURGESS PLEASE DON'T ABUSE THE
PRIVILEGE. THANK THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT ALSO THANK YOU FOR THE
WARNING- COLLEAGUES THAT SOME OF
YOU MAY REMEMBER AND- I THINK IT
WAS A WHITE SPORTS. I BET IT WAS
ON TV PROGRAM ON SATURDAYS AND
SUNDAYS AND THE COMMENTATOR
SAID- WHEN REFERRING TO
ATHLETES- THE THRILL OF VICTORY
AND THE AGONY OF DEFEAT I LOVE
YOU GUYS REMEMBER THAT THAT
SAYING. WELL YESTERDAY A NUMBER
OF US. IN THE LEGISLATURE SOME
OF US HERE IN THIS VERY CHAMBER
EXPERIENCED THE AGONY OF DEFEAT
. BUT ONE. EXPERIENCED THE
THRILL OF VICTORY AND TODAY I'D
LIKE TO- ANNOUNCE THAT OUR TEAM
BORDERS HAS WON THE CALAVERAS.
LEAPING FROG COMPETITION.
CAITLYN ARE CAPITAL FELLOW HAD
THE WINNING FROG I THINK IT WAS
AT TWELVE PM TO SIX INCHES
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT JUST
DECIMATED THE COMPETITION SO- IF
WE COULD JUST GIVE US A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE TO CAITLYN OR CAPITAL
FELLOW- FOR BRINGING HOME FIRST
PLACE IN THE CALAVERAS JUMPING
FROG COMPETITION. TOED THE LINE
BUT DIDN'T ABUSE THE PRIVILEGE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS WE NEED
TO MAKE AND THEN WILL NEED YOUR
ATTENTION- FOR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AT THE END I HAVE WE
CAN GO TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS PLEASE CENTER BY
CAL SKI YOU HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND ENVIRONMENT
PROTECTION AND ENERGY WILL MEET
TWENTY MINUTES UPON THE GERMAN.
TWENTY MINUTES APART ADJOURNMENT
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED I
UNDERSTAND. THANK YOU SONORA
CASKEY SENATOR EGGMAN. AT BUDGET
SUB THREE WILL MEET IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
MINUTES AFTER TWENTY GERMAN.
THANK YOU ROOM FOR SOME THREE
AND TWENTY ONE HUNDRED CENTER
DORADO MISTER PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE BUDGET FIVE WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MINUTES AFTER THE
ADJOURNMENT THANK YOU CENTER
DRAWS A SUB FIVE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE BACK TO. AND RESOLUTIONS
IF WE CAN PLEASE BRING OUR
CONVERSATIONS TO A CLOSE AND OUR
ATTENTION TO THE FLOOR WE HAVE
ONE IN GERMAN MEMORY THIS
MORNING SENATOR ATKINS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MISTER PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES.
ONE OF THE TOUGHEST THINGS THAT
ANYONE CAN GO THROUGH IS OF
COURSE LOSING A FAMILY MEMBER.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. ONE OF
THE TOUGHEST THINGS ANYONE CAN
GO THROUGH IS LOSING A FAMILY
MEMBER SOMETHING THAT PROFOUNDLY
AFFECTS US NO MATTER HOW OLD WE
ARE OR WHERE WE ARE IN LIFE AND
WHEN A MEMBER OF THE SENATE
FAMILY IS MOURNING THE LOSS OF A
LOVED ONE IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO STOP. AND TAKE NOTICE. ON
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTH DONNA
IRENE DELIVER PASSED AWAY FROM
NATURAL CAUSES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. SHE WAS NINETY THREE
YEARS YOUNG. THE MOTHER OF OUR
VERY OWN KIP LIPPER AND ALSO
MOTHER OF DONNA LUCAS A LONGTIME
MEMBER OF THE CAPITAL COMMUNITY.
LESLIE LIVER AND LORENA. DONNA
HAD ALSO SIX GRANDCHILDREN TO
WHOM SHE WAS ABSOLUTELY DEVOTED.
IF I MAY READ JUST A BIT FROM
HER OBITUARY. LET ME TELL YOU
WHY I THINK I MISSED OUT ON
MEETING THE BEST LIPPER. DURING
THE SEASON AT DEL MAR RACETRACK
SHE COULD COMMONLY BE FOUND AT
THE FRONT ROW TABLE OF THE TURF
CLUB. BASEBALL WAS A LIFELONG
PASSION SHE ATTENDED PADRES
GAMES IN PERSON WHEN SHE COULD.
AND WHEN SHE COULDN'T SHE PAID
FOR AN ONLINE SUBSCRIPTION TO
ENSURE SHE COULD VIEW EVERY
SINGLE GAME. THAT IS TO SAY A
WOMAN AFTER MY OWN HEART WE ALL
WISH FOR THAT KIND OF LIFE. BUT
BEFORE THAT SHE WAS AS WE
RECOGNIZE THE OF THE TEACHER A
SCHOOL TEACHER. DONNA WORKED
ALSO IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN THE NINETEEN
FORTIES SO EVEN BEFORE KICK DID
. SHE WORKED FOR SENATOR ORAL
DESMAN OF ELK GROVE WHO PLAYED A
ROLE IN THE FOUNDING OF
SACRAMENTO STATE SHE ALSO WORK
FOR REPRESENTATIVE HELEN GEOGHAN
DOUGLAS ONE OF THE TRAILBLAZING
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA POLITICS.
DON ENJOYED FRIENDS AND TRAVEL
MARTINIS AND HER MOTHER GIGI
ALONG WITH MANY OTHER BLESSINGS
IN HER LONG AND HAPPY LIFE. GIFT
TO YOU AND YOUR ENTIRE FAMILY
YOU ARE IN OUR THOUGHTS. I HOPE
IN THIS THOMAS SAID THIS YOU'RE
ABLE TO REFLECT ON ALL OF THE
HAPPY TIMES. BECAUSE SHE SURE
SOUNDS LIKE A CAKE AND WE ARE SO
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS SO SENATORS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOURNEYING
IN THE MEMORY OF DONNA LIPPER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR I CAN
SENATOR NIELSEN ON THIS ITEM.
YES MR PRESIDENT LADIES
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE. I DID NOT
PERSONALLY KNOW DON LIPPER. BUT
I KNOW SOME OF OUR CHILDREN. AND
YOUR CHILDREN ARE YOUR LEGACY.
AND DO YU JUST KIND OF AN OLD
COUNTRY TERM SHE DONE GOOD.
THEY'VE BEEN A GREAT CREDIT. TO
DONNA AND TO THE INSTITUTION
THAT THEY HAVE SERVED AND WORKED
IN. SO I WANT TO RISE.
COMMENDING HER FOR A WONDERFUL
LIFE. AND CAREER. AND WE WISH
YOU WELL AS SHE GAZES DOWN ON US
FROM HEAVEN. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN. MEMBERS SAYING NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER RECKONS THE DESK
IT'S CLEAR. MISTER PRESIDENT
THANK YOU WELL RUN TODAY I GIVE
YOU MY COMPLIMENTS FOR YOUR
SENSE OF HUMOR END YOUR KEEPING
US ON TRACK. OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY
MAY SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AT TWO PM. THANK YOU SIR RECKONS
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT
WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE PLACED. WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT TWO PM PLEASE HAVE A
GOOD AND SAFE WEEKEND SEE YOU
SOON.